hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night I'm
still a little you know I'm recording
you sequentially obviously so I'm still
a little well I'm okay I'm okay
I think this key might be for the closet
on the fourth floor
huh all right okay no Zack Henry
hey Harry Balzac okay so maybe it was
for this woman I didn't know okay
well darn it must be for something Down
Yonder oh maybe the safe
probably the safe I'll go check down
there okay no more jump scares no more
jump scares my heart can't take it
British say floors down dish in the room
full of death sure that's a spider right
there hello Spidey oh there's another
one you got a friend
kliklak I knew it oh yeah
basement key Oh joyous Oh frabjous day
Callooh Callay I get to go to the
basement
well get busy living or get busy dying
that's what my momma never ever told me
hey honestly she never ever said that in
her entire life while this looks
diabolical with the spikes aw for you
for you not really I don't care
yo dead I'm alive giant pile of bodies
Wow once again I have to appreciate just
looking at this stuff it's wow it's a
gigantic spider oh but don't do anything
it's enormous all of these have spiders
on them you know what things like that
really really cool once again I have to
praise the maker of the mod he's
fantastic I've already told him that I
can't hello
that I can't ah third floor King
um dub okay anyway third floor key let's
go exploring down here but because
there's got to be some more stuff right
I'm a fool to myself and I like to get
myself into trouble myself that's what
my selfie likes to do too and for myself
of which I am a part of me that the
locks look old I need a hammer and
chipper well isn't that
fan-freakin'-tastic nah derp derp
oh I broke it again oh all right screw
that I'm not going in there
I'm not cuz I'm not gonna ruin anything
else that this guy's cooked up obviously
hammer and chipper I got to go to the
third floor I'm not gonna ruin this guy
but but I am just too good at finding
bug and I swear I freakin used a hammer
or the shovel to leverage the door off
its hinges and I I don't even know how I
did that I'm just so incredible I'm I'm
beyond incredible that's what I am okay
but anyway we're gonna ignore that that
didn't happen you didn't see a thing I
hope that's straight I can't really see
but you didn't see a thing I didn't
screw up
everything that doesn't sound like me at
all
what are you talking about okay anyway
going up to the side anybody no fix it
yeah or maybe no depending on how this
turns out
No
ah I had to hit the desk because I was
about to punch my monitor oh I keep
leaving my lantern out when I do that oh
you do you guys I was so focused on that
thing and it oh that's the first time
I've had like a physical inclination to
hit something I always seen that video
of the of of the guy who's being like
interviewed out of high school and also
and this guy pops out a trash man and he
just punches him right in the face
Avenue is hilarious but I don't want to
punch my very expensive and very nice
monitor crash yeah you know what's up
crash before I even got to you I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
ooh boy if I tell myself I'm okay
eventually I'll be okay
alright I'm okay I'm not sure if I'm
more happy that my heart is still
beating or that it's going slowly down
what was in this room there was nothing
here was there wait a minute I just
fooling myself there's nothing in here
right what maybe a room with nothing in
it what's the point of the room then
it's got to be something in there
no fireplace nope
oh there nope
all right then I guess it was just
nothing maybe a hiding place or
something cuz it monsters about to spawn
okay this guy's has a serious obsession
with these not the guy the owner of the
house but the maker of the mod there was
locked
oh this looks good
hello
No
[Music]
nothing here
I want to conserve my oil but I want it
open what the hell is that noise
[Music]
this can't be master has locked us on
the third floor and let loose the
monsters here all he said was that this
is a test and so since on I'm trying to
hide what they are killing everyone in
here and I'm really scared that I'm the
next on the list if I live through this
I will kill him crap something is coming
I need to hide okay it was nothing but
they are out there what
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay all right then nothing just a
joke
for the little lock
I do not like this place I don't like it
I don't hire extra unknown mega do not
like it okay so that's a problem this is
a good door
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
huh BAM totally connected the dots
they're not sure if this is a good thing
again because I could be just screwing
myself although we got here a dead grunt
hammer are something changed it lagged
something must have changed
DejaVu what I saw a cat no I saw a
similar cat no thank you
why am i opening that door ear
regardless
irregardless nope
oh thank you good thing I got those
boxes out of there oh my gosh
go away loose man
[Music]
I can't see a damn thing in here I swear
it's like pitch black oh there we can
finally yuk F right off fudge right off
I'm trying to be better about my curse
again I don't like to be you know just
crude but sometimes I can't help it
y'see right there okay I got the hammer
but I don't have a chipper I need to get
the chipper and then I need to get out
of here
I can see him I can see the little
outline of it it's over there why oh god
do I just have to aw probably I just
have this thing fine don't look at him
I'm not looking where'd you go I still
there I'm not look I'm about to go
insane
okay he went around the corner there was
this it was this a weak one that we cool
could I use that up damn door oh this
looks nice
don't didn't know jump scares I've never
seen that before
fifteen seconds huh why what are you
what do i do what do I do aah no aah in
here open what do I do I won't open no
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no you can't see
me Oh can't see me you cannot see me I'm
hidden still see like bull
[Music]
this is actually working
or am i deluding myself boop boop beep I
can't believe this is actually working
[Music]
he was quite there for a bit No thank
you sir
I will by next year go away now maybe
this is not how he intended for me to do
this go away there you go there you go
oh god damn it
okay all right oh this is hammer key
pausing no yep nope
oh this is dead and I'm so bone I'm so
bone I'm cell phone get out of here I
fired up where are you oh no sure you
I'm gonna wait what about this one
already one in here no this is a closer
yeah I'm Way over time okay all right
I'm I'm out I'm out I'm done I'm done
I'm done I'm done thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye